[Music]
we know that more than a million
migrants came to Europe in the biggest
exodus since World War two
what isn't well-documented is the plight
of the weak the injured and those who
struggle to make it
this is the tale of two Syrian boys
caught up in the migration lottery it's
springtime in the Greek capital Athens
and after a hard winter the days are
getting warmer which for most migrants
makes survival easier but not everyone
we sit in the shade to meet one of the
boys a nine year old who can't face
direct sunlight
Manon is pictured with his sister Nath
Lea a few years ago
this is him now he suffered third-degree
burns to much of his body and needs
plastic surgery after escaping from
Syria fire broke out in his family's
tent not in a war zone
but in a migrant camp here in Greece
volunteers Salam al Deen has been
helping the family and shows us a video
of the night of the fire you can hear
the screams of man Anne's mother she had
to choose which of her children to try
to rescue from the flames first
she's aged Nath Lia sparing at least one
child
no serious injury nobody got inside to
save the baby
the mother jumped inside them but the
baby no man got inside them to get the
baby she took her
[Music]
and when it had
they're addictive
Greece is the first European country for
many migrants arriving on the continent
but Gateway borders North are now closed
and Greece is ill-equipped to deal with
the influx all the injuries of those who
fled war there are no official figures
but charities have told Sky News they
estimate there are several thousand
high-risk children here in need of
specialist medical help Greek people
have been wonderful but because there is
such an exodus of refugees coming to
Greece the medical services are
overstretched thirteen-year-old najeev
ali also made it to Greece from Syria
he's undergoing tests at a hospital in
Athens his final promise
with his hometown of Holmes has been
bombarded by Syrian government forces
and he was caught up in one of the
airstrikes in 2013 with devastating
consequences Najib was so badly injured
he was left unable to walk Jimmy and I
hired get a note fat it and to feel
Campbell de Rossi Wilhelm addressee
character you have been addressing her
brief Ricardo her bit like her be food
battle it's not below like if a bit
cloudy her before the charity goodwill
Caravan has arranged a private
appointment it's the first time Mujeeb
and his family have been able to see a
specialist consultant after a year in
greece Najib is already in a wheelchair
but doctors have discovered new problems
he is told he needs an urgent even
life-saving operation the teenager has
the kidneys of an old man and is facing
the prospect of renal failure he's got a
serious neurological problem that needs
to be dealt with pretty soon in order
not to jeopardize his kidney function
and not having him ends up in entirety
is something that would be very
debilitating the Jeep's family left
Syria as refugees not only having lost
their home but in the hope of finding
someone to help their son walk again
still reeling from news of the teenagers
kidney problems the next day they
arrived to see a leading spinal
consultant at a government hospital
you think that last year
if we let ya know let's try this side
you feel it do you feel anything here
this is a not much movement really
doesn't have any any conscious movement
of his legs and then he had a girl in
her the other he had a grizzly and
Haruka Heidi a lot a lot it had a Cobra
do you think that there's any chance he
could walk again
I think this is this very slim invisible
were seeking initial incursion
hello son mother fishy
as Najib battles injuries from four
years ago the family's home town has
been hit again with a fresh strike
Najib's grandparents lived in the house
next door mom I'm sure
London addressed
[Music]
fyodor Coolio man that silly Najib's
father Talal is reliant on the goodwill
of a passerby to help with the
wheelchair he banked on getting his son
to Europe so he could try to walk again
but will borders north of Greece closed
they're now stuck and can't be sure if
or even when Najeeb will get the
treatment he needs
Ali also is the father of burns victim
Manan he gambled on going to Germany
ahead of his family to claim asylum back
in 2015 with the migration crisis at its
peak Germany was offering a warm welcome
to Syrians fleeing war and it's where
Ali went hoping his wife and children
would be allowed to follow but Ali's
dreams were shattered when word came
that his son Manan had suffered
life-changing burns in a fire at a
migrant camp in Greece it's now three
months since we first met Manan and he's
made it to Berlin in Germany with his
mother and sister they were given
permission to join father Ali after
being accepted on the migrant
reunification program massive table
methodically Cujo it's nice to look over
this way I'm the Martindale Holloman at
a camp hardly any much open evening
the family are now on their way to a
specialist hospital in Berlin to begin a
program of treatment paid for by the
German government it is a moment man
Anne's mother has both hoped for and
feared knowing years of operations lie
ahead
to treat the burns which have disfigured
her son until now man Anne has only had
basic emergency treatment in Greece
after the fire this is the first time
German specialists have been able to
carry out the full examination of the
injuries he will have to live with for
the rest of his life as Manon gets
bigger he's told his scarred skin won't
stretch making movement of his legs and
feet more difficult don't just say the
immediate focus is his left hand and
face
[Music]
here that you can open the mouth he
can't completely closed his eyes to
blink properly willfully open his mouth
smiling is virtually impossible it's a
lot to take in for a little boy Evelina
like anything you give I love Who I am
I'm Yuki better than if he man and
doesn't recognize his own reflection
waha TRAI we don't layer I had a lot
higher but the pain of what Manon went
through in Greece is still fresh in his
mind
a few weeks later and Manan is wheeled
into the operating theatre
[Music]
[Applause]
four surgeons work simultaneously on his
hand and face my nan lost the top part
of his fingers on his left hand by
making incisions in the skin that's left
it's hope new fingers can be partially
created doctors are trying to help my
nan smile again but he will also have to
learn to live with his scars
[Music]
surgeons in Germany have been operating
on Manan also a nine-year-old Syrian boy
for more than three hours
he suffered catastrophic burns to his
face and hands when his tent caught fire
in a migrant camp in Greece we just
finished the first step of
reconstruction in this boy and basically
is well was all about the face and the
left hand so this was the primary or the
more severe points that we wanted to
address he had a problem to close the
right eye so we did a correction of the
inner limbus of the right eye and we
opened up a bit the orifice of the mouth
so that he's able to open the DND mouth
more the process will go over his life
maybe it could be that we have in 15
years essentially maybe we have some
steps in the next months maybe in the
next two years then maybe we have to
quake and he grows up and then we go
again
maybe that's a future his disfigured
face has prevented Manan or his parents
from wanting him to start school in
berlin they hope this will take him a
step nearer to leading something of a
normal life we know that as a child that
they always have a fear from their look
and they are afraid that other children
they're gonna laugh at them or be
uncomfortable to be next to them so our
target and goal is to let them to live
with their scars and to adapt
back in Greece thirteen-year-old Najib
Ali who was left paralyzed when his home
in Syria was hit in an airstrike is
still on a waiting list for treatment
we've been given rare permission to film
a meeting between Najib's family the
charity goodwill caravan who are helping
him and a British government official
one option is to try to get him a visa
to travel to the reconstructive spinal
surgery can be done here however there
aren't enough specialists for the
rehabilitation when he wakes up from the
operation crucially the official wants
to know if they can pay for the
treatment themselves if they go to the
UK but in order to talk to London to
explain to them I need to know because I
think the financing and all that it is
their bonus with you in the UK you know
very well what's going on
but he know also the the political
climates in the UK so with everything
that is going on at the moment about the
the one person cap on health workers in
their NHS not being underfunded you can
see where the politicians are going to
be even a little bit privately funded
treatment seems to be Najib's best hope
but in Germany burns victim Manan has
already had a number of operations paid
for by the government since I first met
both the boys I know that they wanted to
come here of course to be reunited with
man Anne's father but not only that
because for my nan being here in Germany
represents a real opportunity for him to
get the medical treatment he needs
hello I've come back to Germany to see
man and his family for what is a
momentous occasion man Anne is finally
going to start school good yeah it's
been a few months since his operation
whilst my Nan's left hand is still in a
cast the scars from the operation on his
face by healing well mana what do you
remember about the fire
look at me mr. Tonko Stan I suggested
man and his sister Natalia are extremely
close but haven't mixed much with other
children since the fire look what scared
me was you know me as such God we were
let's go at it isn't
[Music]
hello hello hello yeah hello man on my
name is tected I know in plots ok yes my
man is seen yaha right ok senior back on
comm VI [ __ ] 400 Julian back on the
hosnian Ali Ahmed on Khalid you know you
can't Assyrian this is a welcome class
for children who've come to Germany from
all over the world it's the first time
my nan has ever been to school in any
country in his first words of German man
and introduces himself he smiles when
his classmates applaud him something he
would have found virtually impossible
before the operation to help him feel
more comfortable he sat with other
children from Arab speaking countries
including another Syrian boy who was
born with disabilities to his hand and
foot even his new friend who turns out
to be from the same town in Syria was
curious about the new arrival we have in
the classroom we say all the children
the same nobody have nobody is a mistake
because we have something maybe he have
not a whole hand maybe some child cannot
hear some child want to don't want to
speak but we all are perfect like we are
was on the way out in the playground
bananas worst fears are realized
as he becomes the center of attention
[Music]
being stared at is something man and
will have to contend with for the rest
of his life in the Greek capital Athens
Najib Ali and his family are losing hope
unable to walk Najib is now 14 and his
parents and brothers are struggling to
lift him nearly seven months ago Najib
was told he faced the possibility of
dialysis without a kidney operation but
he's still on a waiting list
his mother fattens says she would
willingly give up one of her own kidneys
if she could find someone to operate but
it's not only his kidney lung and
bladder problems that are weakening
Najib his collapsed spine which still
has shrapnel in it is pushing the Jeebs
abdomen to one side causing him intense
pain his family say they never dreamed
they would be stuck in Athens like this
lost a loved one
little Bradley here they are but I do
not have energy in Berlin Manan has had
the cast taken off his left hand
revealing partial fingers the surgery
around his mouth means he can now eat
and drink more easily
[Music]
aoyama-kun
[Music]
Najib's family have now got residency in
Greece they're in the process of
applying for a visa to travel to Britain
to try to get treatment for him
[Music]
welcome to the roasted garlic
[Music]
you